[Musique]
hier complètement rasées il va parler
marny est un chat d'intérieur elle ne
sort jamais interdit voici les infos
cambriolage a été commis ce matin dans
la commune de drap ville à la ferme de
la fei ici les habitants sont révoltés
par ce cambriolage ont la balle un
policier complètement nu que ces infos
sont de plus en plus pénible à regarder
enfin j'ai une enquête à mener mois
et le jour où lyon de boules de monsieur
rennes scène pourquoi je ferme il ne
peut pas décider lui-même qui doit aller
dans la mare but qui est projet
adhérez à bien faire tomber le deuxième
quart pour british
[Musique]
mais par hazard pourrait que voiture et
je remettrai 4 étoiles pour la
conversation
ma petite part elle n'est perdu il ne
connaît rien à la ville et eu l'agent
spécial mareuil de charme et une enquête
sur les cambriolages qui ont été commis
dans la région au les chats il se croit
toujours les meilleurs mais si on
travaille en équipe on peut découvrir j
ai cette bande de voleurs
il semblerait que votre minette portier
nippon pour l'europe où la vitesse est
limitée à 30 les panneaux de limitation
je vais te montrer à quoi ça sert
dans le filet lisant ton voyage avec un
gros coup droit
on se sent vraiment
tu veux que je te dise qui me plaît chez
toi levé c'est pas facile
t'es sûr pouvoir pilote piège dangereux
j'ai comme une camionnette non à
[Musique]
j'ai oublié mon corps d'eau salée la
faire bouillir
[Musique]